je vous annonce ce soir qu' à titre
syndical on a récupéré un certain nombre
d'enregistrements de patrouille à qui on
est et qui ont été gérés des dont la
capture a été effectué et justement en
dehors d'eux
on va dire de façon discrète parce que
en réponse justement aux propos du
ministre donateurs qui a accès qui a
expliqué le 5 février dernier à
l'antenne de vos confrères de france
inter qu'il n'y avait pas de racisme
antimaghrébin ou anti musulmans dans la
police lui l'a affirmé comme une
certitude que nous allons nous exercer à
lui démontrer le contraire justement et
je pense qu'il le sait très bien dans le
fond si vous voulez la difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement le
gouvernement a besoin de la police donc
tout est fait pour que le ministre de
l'intérieur ne se met pas justement la
police via les syndicats majoritaires à
dos les syndicats de police sont
politisés de toute façon on voit bien
qu'il ya un usage du droit du règlement
administratif à géométrie variable
c'est-à-dire que bon globalement et peut
être légitimement vous êtes pro
palestiniens vous êtes viré si vous
l'exprimer mais aujourd'hui dans la
police et j'assume pleinement mon propos
quand vous êtes raciste anti noir anti
arabes et anti musulmans ou anti ce que
vous voulez et parfois même antisémite
d'ailleurs il ya une forme de tolérance
que je ne m'explique pas est un exemple
très précis du tribunal du tgi de rouen
qui date d'environ un mois qu'il
démontre très bien les extraits audio
ont été mis en ligne par certains de vos
confrères où les mots s'ils voulaient
pendant des mois et des semaines
entières biko juifs etc
s'il ya une déferlante de haine raciale
justement sur des échanges entre les
fonctionnaires de police
et si vous voulez moi je ne m'explique
pas la faible réaction avec un
communiqué rapide pour dire que je crois
que le fonctionnaire qui avait signalé
les faits qui lui est d'origine
antillaise a été déplacé donc moi si
j'avais été ministre de l'intérieur ce
qui n'arrivera jamais donc je peux me
permettre justement moi j'aurais
déplacer les dix personnes responsables
justement des propos et j'aurais laissé
la victime en place justement au tj dron
[Musique]